and I thankful we live in a free country
it is free where you're free to say dumb
stuff and man we've heard a lot of that
this year a president who is not fit to
lead who's gonna do something crazy in
five minutes one hour tonight or
tomorrow like what more do you need to
hear from him to start thinking 25th
amendment or something else
how does she sleep at night anyway and
there's this the worst case scenario
that the president is a foreign agent
suddenly feels very public it could be a
robot too and who can forget who could
forget this this president has
radicalized so many more people than
Isis ever did deserves an award just one
more in the sad event he does run and he
does lose which would be a happy event
it would be stunning
what we would see would be a president
I'm not leaving I'm not leaving could
call the military I mean it is that we
have to look at this man I really would
do that they really are the political
equivalent of beavis and butthead but
what's really important is this America
now has the hottest economy on earth we
have taken historic action to bring back
American jobs we will make America
wealthy again we will make America
strong again we will make America great
again all right look
I think they're clapping for me but it's
okay the relationship between Trump in
the media it may never change but when
talking heads are saying outrageous
things
doesn't that mean maybe the country's
relatively okay maybe that things are
running smoothly so there's no recession
to talk about no impending international
crisis knock on fake wood and
chick-fil-a delivers to your house now
so things are pretty good unless you're
a chicken so yeah you'll hear a lot of
bad stuff from the Talking Heads and the
president will throw it right back at
them it's like watching this soap opera
the actors are all over the top the
dialogue is cheesy the storylines are
ridiculous
oh he will leave if he's not reluctant
come on you jerk he'll start a coup shut
up yet festering gasbag and yet but with
any good soap we the viewers just sit
there and think oh my god I can't stop
watching this crap and it is crap but
that's okay as long as you don't take it
too seriously
as for the Talking Heads will they be
thankful for Trump he's been good for
their business too mainly because
without him they'd be extremely boring
and there's nothing worse than that well
maybe there is it's always fun to get
together with friends and family
[Applause]
all right let's welcome tonight's guest
he's a prescription filler and my
favorite painkiller host of the radio
show dr. droop mint day live dr. Drew
Pinsky look at him he's funny and highly
strung like a tennis racket made from
clown guts comedian Joe Mackey you know
for Thanksgiving she and her cat shared
a Swanson's turkey dinner National
Review reporter cat Tim he lives in two
time zones and he doesn't even fly
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
in home
say on fox nation Pyrus alright dr. drew
could you imagine if we had instead of
Trump we had Hillary Hillary would we be
enjoying this kind of auto bonanza would
you call it a news bonanza no they've
gotta remember news is a commercial
enterprise and they are addicted to
President Trump right they are he
controls the news cycle they're addicted
to him they get some ratings but had he
not been elected president there would
have been something about the people
that put him in the presidency we'd be
hearing from I think yes worse way yes
that's true and you are an addiction
specialist yes by the way how am i doing
you're doing great but but some of the
news outlets or officially addicted well
I was referring to the window cleaner
yes yeah you know I'm no longer doing
that you're not gonna paint anymore no
no no I'm just just purely just uh doing
mints okay Joe way better Joe love the
jacket thank you yeah I guess yeah
members-only is back in style
don't let anyone buy these great yeah
certainly will the country's doing okay
so what are you worried about I'm
worried that Crazy's becoming a relative
term now I'm sure to some politicians a
politician like Trump who says what he
thinks and doesn't try to hide his
demeanor might seem nuts Hillary Clinton
yes that's true
you know it's what he is saying
basically everything that's on his mind
and most of that stuff is what some most
of us kind of think I guess well I mean
I think the crazy ones sometimes seem
like the pundits someone's gonna say
call the military there's no such person
as the military you can't call up and
say hello of a military
that's so true
cat what do you make of what's your
what's your take this year on how it's
going as we're getting towards 2019 well
I've got some issues but none of them
have to do with Trump
would you care to share them not my dad
told me not to do that anymore I just
talked to dr. drew now okay yeah I just
I think that they don't realize that
they love it because if Trump didn't say
sometimes out there things then they
wouldn't have anything to talk about
right no they don't they just look at
his Twitter and they say aw he's
tweeting stuff at 3:00 in the morning
again I can write about how he's
unhinged or how he's crazy and
everyone's gonna love it and it's just
this they don't have to actually do any
research anymore it's so easy I'm even
saying that for myself right this has
been fun and easy it's like a B it's
like being a kid and being able to have
ice cream for breakfast lunch and dinner
that's what it's like in the media for
Trump and you just feel sick all the
time because you haven't even somebody
so much ice cream Tyrus yeah and a quick
fast-track to diabetes - yeah yes maybe
not dummy I still got the itis so
forgive me for talking slow not telling
you but look even when he doesn't say
anything they'll just make something up
right they didn't really have any good
quotes after the midterms so he's pissed
yes the white house is dark well it's a
Saturday everybody's off so the lights
are probably off so good chance but I
just
he's just they have to say his name
mm-hmm there's probably a rule like in
my football locker we used to come out
we used to smack it was a deer antler
would he smacked the sign before we go
out and play I literally when they come
out of there I guess the reporters have
locker rooms let's just say they do they
come out and I'll be like trump at least
16 times per segment like it's just they
have a moniker they got him at because
every time you mention his name
even if you don't have a story make
something up chances are he'll probably
go that way anyway so yeah you know
that's you and he provides he provides
three things for a great story he could
be the hero the villain and he provides
the focus which was the opposite of
President Obama where the media dare not
scrutinize him because you could get in
trouble but everyday it's an
all-you-can-eat buffet with Trump you
can get Trump casserole Trump eggs from
sausage Trump potatoes well Gregg I'm
still trying to get over the whole food
thing I'm making you hungry yeah I mean
the other thing too is I think the media
is upset that it's become a bifurcated
idea they long for the days when it was
a monolith where everybody was behind
one vision and it was this mythical
Walter Cronkite right
and then now it's changed and they talk
about divisive 'native well they've
confused news with opinion and talk
shows with news yes is a talk show we're
having yes yes sometimes I think I'm
dreaming this and I'm in a hospital
you're in the simulation oh this is a
simulation
I just don't know who's running a Doctor
Who